hey youtubers is Charlie so there's a
new rogue one trailer coming tomorrow is
basically like the Darth Vader
celebration trailer but there's gonna be
a bunch of other new stuff so here's a
breakdown so the big thing in this
teaser is the new you wing ship they've
been talking about that a lot this week
you've actually seen it in footage
before without realizing it it's kind of
like a proto version of the x-wing the
why wait like the classic designs that
you see from the original trilogy so
what we learned is that in the
behind-the-scenes footage they did its
celebration space monkey is he's
cheering and firing the gun here he's
inside of one of these ships so as is
the case with the teasers they drop
between big trailers they just he's like
one new thing but tomorrow during the
Olympics you know I assume during the
evening they're gonna be dropping the
big trailer that they said they were
going to drop during celebration so if
you were in a celebration they aired a
new trailer for the audience there that
had Darth Vader in it it was really like
the same trailer that we've seen before
like I did a video for us I'll put a
link in the description but at the end
of it like the extra footage that they
only screened for the celebration
audience was just like a brief couple
seconds of Vader walking and breathing
heavily he wasn't speaking or anything
like that but James Earl Jones did come
back to do the voice so he will sound
like the Vader that you remember it'll
be the Darth Vader trailer that we were
promised but did not get a couple weeks
ago so yay for that I'm hoping that they
change it up just a little bit too
because we've already seen most of that
footage but we're still a long ways out
from the movie dropping it's not coming
till this December so I'm expecting them
to save like one last big trailer with a
bunch of new footage usually there's
like three big trailers that are very
very different from each other but the
other really cool thing that's not
evident from these trailers Donnie Yen
was talking about a but just I know he
released his spoiler about his character
at celebration so if you do want to talk
about that just please use spoiler tags
in the comments but he revealed that the
planet that there are that the Empire's
onto this big mission is taking place
near is called Jedi
as in Jedi because like the really
important thing is that they mind Kyber
crystals therefore lightsabers but the
Empire is also using those crystals to
power the Death Star so that explains
why this planet in particular is so
important to the empire why they have so
much going on here in how that figures
in to the construction of the first
Death Star so on the flipside is also
really cool because thematically you
have this thing that's typically
used by the Jedi for good being twisted
for evil which is kind of like the
unofficial core operating mission of the
empire in the Star Wars movies but I'm
not really expecting the movie to get
super technical with the way they
explain how the Death Star super laser
is constructed they'll probably have
like some cool diagrams in some really
simple way of explaining it on screen so
that everybody can understand and then
in the expanded material like in all the
books and the comics and stuff that's
where they'll spell it out so if you
were one of those fans after the
original trilogy came out that pored
over blueprints of the Death Star and
Star Destroyers like I was a big fan of
the d6 role-playing Star Wars game they
had a bunch of awesome diagrams and
description of ships but then several
years after that they changed the
role-playing system to D 20 if you don't
know what I'm talking about don't worry
about it it's just a part of the
expanded universe that they use for
getting super technical with stuff so
it's just part of the fun of the movie
like you go for this story and then
after it like the third and fourth time
you watch the movie you start poring
over blueprints and looking at all the
relate technical stuff so I'm really
excited about all these spin-off films
the other big thing too I don't know if
it's controversial I don't think it's
that controversial is that another way
that they're differentiating these
spin-off films from the main films is
that there won't be an opening title
crawl at least they've been hinting that
there might not like Kathleen Kennedy is
like yeah we might not use the opening
title crawl we really want this to feel
like a different thing from the main
series so you guys can let me know in
the comments like what do you think
about them doing a Star Wars film or
series of Star Wars films like the
spin-off films without the opening title
crawl it just feels like such a Star
Wars storytelling device that it is
gonna be weird to hear that Lucasfilm
fanfare and then not see it pop up but
just reminder new big Star Wars trailer
dropping tomorrow night of course I'm
gonna do a video for it so be sure to
subscribe to get that my next video is
gonna be a thor ragnarok bill in video
they were just talking about Fenris wolf
Firelord Serdar Loki
like Tom Hiddleston himself was posting
pictures in the costume he's like I'm
back so that video will post
later tonight so get hype well you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
to watch the behind the scenes footage
again and you can click here to learn
all about the next Suicide Squad movie
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]